NASA's Swift satellite detected this
gamma-ray burst just as I dropped my
daughter off at school and I got the
message essentially from the satellite
on my mobile phone telling me that it
had happened
three two one we have ignition and we
have liftoff of NASA's Swift spacecraft
on a mission to study and understand
gamma-ray bursts throughout the universe
when massive stars explode they can
produce gamma-ray bursts the bursts
reported in nature is the earliest
discrete event seen so far in our
universe astronomers have long had the
holy grail of trying to find what they
call primeval galaxies the very first
and earliest galaxies to form in what
period of time between the Big Bang
itself and the first stars turning on in
the universe and that kind of dark age
era is a real focus of modern research
trying to understand how structures in
the universe came into existence when I
received the text message about the
gamma-ray burst it came ultimately from
the Swiss satellite Swift is an unusual
satellite at the back you have the burst
alert telescope which detects the gamma
rays from the gamma ray burst and here
on the left is the x-ray telescope when
Swift detects our bursts it's lose the
whole spacecraft around and points these
narrower field high resolution
telescopes at that patch of the sky
and so the x-ray telescope detects the
x-rays from the fading afterglow of the
gamma-ray burst and that gives us a
precise position and then an optical
telescope which also takes a picture of
the same patch of the sky
joining Neil kanva along with a global
team was Andrew levan so when you look
at the image of this gamma-ray burst
what you actually see is a very faint
red blob which is the afterglow as it
gradually fades away and that of course
is in many ways unremarkable and the
reason for that is because it is
incredibly far away and so the distance
coupled with the expansion of the
universe really makes it very very faint
what Hubble told us back in the 1930s
was that there is a direct relationship
between the speed at which an object is
moving away from us and its actual
distance in space and so what we do when
we measure the redshift is essentially
we measure the velocity of the object
which is moving away from us the Doppler
shift is something of course we're all
very familiar with when you hear a car
coming along the road towards you if
it's coming fast you hear it making a
high-pitched sound of the noise of its
engine
it's that new that is when the the car
is moving away from you the extra
velocity stretches out the sound waves
and that leads to a lower tone
essentially when we look out into space
we're trying to make use of exactly the
same technique we take the light and we
put it through a slit which disperses it
and so it's a bit like taking up
sunlight and putting it through a prism
of making a rainbow this is the evidence
that we live in an expanding universe
well we have here as galaxies at ever
greater distances there are some little
dark bands and certain bright lines if
we bring up the locations of those lines
this one due to hydrogen here this wants
you to oxygen the further away the
galaxies the further to the red end of
the spectrum the particular lines move
then this bottom one this galaxy is
moving away from us at nearly a hundred
thousand kilometers per second
and the gamma-ray bursts signal to
researchers just were these ancient
galaxies are but just how are these
extraordinarily energetic bursts
produced what we think gamma-ray bursts
are formed by is the final collapse a
very massive star perhaps 20 or so times
the mass of the Sun and as they run out
of nuclear fuel in their core they
collapse and in the center they form a
black hole and the matter raining on to
this black hole produces a powerful jet
pierces the star these two Jets expand
outwards but what calls for autistic
speeds that is very very close to the
speed of light and so it is these two
jets which you see forming at the core
here and then moving apart which are the
gamma-ray bursts and if you're an
observer sitting somewhere on this jet
so a long aligned along this axis then I
see a gamma-ray burst
when these gamma-ray bursts occur they
are a brilliant flash of light that's
picked up by the spacecraft but then the
fading ember what we call the afterglow
fades away on a timescale of hours and
so if we want to find out about these
events and study them in any kind of
detail work out how far away they are
when they occurred then we have to get
our observations made really rapidly
throughout the day it actually became
more and more clear that this was a
particularly exceptional event and once
we realized that we alerted potentially
the world to that fact astronomers
around the world hurriedly turned their
instruments towards the ancient
exploding star another team using this
information were able to obtain a
spectrum about 13 or 14 hours after the
gamma-ray burst from which they were
also able to independently make it the
redshift this international team
including Rubin Salva tera Guido Contini
and Massimo Della Valle amongst others
wrote the second paper appearing in
nature they used the La Palma telescope
in the Canary Islands to obtain a
spectrum of the bursts some hours before
the UK team could one of the great
things about having in this case two
different groups making similar but
independent observations which came up
with essentially the same answer is that
everyone out there can be reassured that
the answer is robust and that we haven't
made any kind of mistake
they're brighter than anything else that
we see in the universe so in principle
you should be able to see them really
far away perhaps further than anything
else we've ever seen I just put that
incredible luminosity into some kind of
context if this were an isotropic
explosion when the kind of power we're
talking about is about ten to the 46
what's that pink from these versa that's
what we've been waiting for but it took
us all this time waiting and following
up many such gamma-ray bursts in order
to find one which was a real record
breaker which this one turned out to be
with gamma-ray bursts of course we've
got to do everything with double quick
time it's it does make it tremendously
exciting who knows you could have a
great new discovery tomorrow and we have
no idea today that that was going to
happen this is an incredibly exciting
way to do astronomy because obviously
you have to chase these bursts in real
time so so every time your phone goes to
alert you to the fact that the gamma-ray
bursts are the surprise in store for you